I saw them as the boss pulled up they  were standing there they made a sign and  stuff like that the little guy our son  he couldn't get or but the sound of my  voice said why does your voice sound  like that so that's what it always  sounds like buddy when you're that small  nine months you know like almost a  quarter of his life what is the hardest  thing to miss that these past nine  months the hugs that's someone I didn't  really remember missing that feeling  that feeling that you know you can  actually touch them now guys ready to go  watch Star Wars - yeah you just take a  step back off to the sidelines for a  second and watch everyone else like  receive their family in that moment it  is like genuinely one of the happiest  times